I feel like the lifestyle of having the flexibility of Bug Bounty as well has bred some really
unexpected but cool opportunities, which I just never would have guessed could have happened.
The best part of hacking is when you can just, you know, critical thing.
All right, hackers, we all know the value of a good misconfiguration, right? That's often how we're
popping bugs and bug bounties. Well, unfortunately, ThreatLocker also knows about it, which is why
they built DAC, Defense Against Configurations. DAC scans all of the enterprise machines in your
network for misconfigurations, ranks them by severity, and then shows them in nice graphics
in a portal. It even emails your team weekly with updates, so nothing slips through the cracks.
And the best part about DAC, in my opinion, is that it actually maps all these misconfigurations
onto security frameworks, and it also shows you how to fix them. That way, when you need ammo with
leadership or with IT, you can point to real specific compliance gaps and get actionable steps.
Anyway, check out ThreatLocker DAC. It's an awesome way to stay ahead of these
issues that we as attackers love. All right, let's go. Back to the show.
Alrighty, sup, hackers. We got the This Week in Bug Bounty segment, and I guess
I'll start this week off actually with a shout out to the Epic Games team for an amazing live hacking
event in Sweden this past week. I had a blast. So much fun and currently in first place. Gotta say,
you know, not a bad time for me. But yeah, really, the team was excellent there and definitely wanted
to give them a shout out because that was a S-tier event. And the way that they interacted with the
hackers, collaborated, escalated bugs. Phenomenal. Phenomenal. You rarely see an experience like that,
that detailed at a live hacking event where they really checked every box. So anyway, I'm kind of
glowing, as you guys can tell from a really awesome week of hacking. Damn, this is such a great job,
guys. We really have the most amazing job. All right, so let's get into the content for this week,
for the This Week in Bug Bounty. First up, we've got an article by Yes We Hack. Once again, just
releasing these ultimate guides on various bug classes. Really digging this series. It's great
for getting in-depth analysis of your methodology for various bug class. And this week is race
conditions. Now, race conditions is something I don't actually do very much of because I'm using Kaido,
and we don't have a bunch of tooling right now for race conditions. But this blog outlines the different
kind of attacks you can do with HTTP 1.1, last byte synchronization attacks, and HTTP 2, single packet
race condition attacks, which we've talked about a lot in the pod. Really awesome stuff here. So check it
out if you're interested in sort of brushing up on race condition vulnerabilities. Also, crazy from Yes We Hack,
the dojo just got a total facelift, guys. So check this out. For those on YouTube, check out my screen right
now. Super beautiful design here. And as always, Yes We Hack is running awesome challenges on dojo-yeswehack.com.
This month's is chainfection, which looks like some file upload vulnerabilities happening here. So always
good to check that out if you guys are looking to sharpen your skills. And what a lot of people don't
know is when you solve these dojo challenges, you get points and invites on Yes We Hack. So pretty awesome.
All right. Last but not least, guys, I told you a couple weeks ago that Bug Crowd, specifically Santera,
was looking for people to come and do PR opportunities, right? Well, for those of you that are watching the
screen right now, you are looking at my boy, grep me Brandon on TV in Britain via those opportunities
with Bug Crowd. So definitely if you're a top skill hacker, shoots and Tara an email, say, Hey, I'm open
to PR opportunities. And you might end up on TV like Brandon did in this scenario. So anyway, just wanted to
shoot that out. If you guys are interested in seeing the segment, we'll link it in the description. And with
that we'll jump right into the show. Let's go. Hey, hey, what's up, guys? I am here with Brandon
grep me. You may remember him from a few months ago. Did you say it was like seven or eight months ago?
I think it was around about that time. It was during the my first LHE, actually, just after.
Nice. And at that time, you had been hacking for like a year had been doing bug binding for about a year.
Yeah. At the time of the last interview, it had only been eight or nine months. So in bug binding
specifically. So I was still in that very rich learning process, first LHE, coming to terms with
everything. And yeah, it's been a crazy ride since then.
Sweet. Yeah. And so Justin and you obviously like knew each other back then. And then you kind
of have been doing hacker notes through this year. But what the audience probably doesn't know is that
you and I have done a bunch of hacking together this year on a mix of AI products and bug binding
programs and even a pen test here or there. So this guy is is a, you know, what I would consider,
you know, top tier kind of AI security hacker as well. And we'll talk a little about that later in
the episode. But first, yeah, I wanted to hear, you know, what what you've been up to for this year?
How has going full time been? You know, what's it look like?
Yeah, full time. As I said, it's been a bit of a journey and I feel like the lifestyle of having the
flexibility of bug bounty as well has bred some really unexpected but cool opportunities, which I
just never would have guessed could have happened without having the flexibility of doing bug bounty.
So I've been full time since January. So what is that? Eight months, eight months, nine months.
I've participated in a few more in person events since then. I've taken home awards from in person events
a few times, which has been really nice. And yeah, it's just been such a good journey. And I'm
very grateful for the community and being able to do it really, dude. Yeah, I didn't even thought
about the fact that we went full time in the same month. That's awesome. We actually did. And that was
when do you remember the hack bot that we absolutely wrecked and dropped to create in the high end?
Yeah, that was like the I feel like that was like the real gateway, but that was literally within the
first week or two of me going full time. I feel like that was the gateway for like the AI hacking when
I was like, right, this is really something I'm going to go down now. Yeah, contributed to a bunch of the
findings and invites through this year and how all that shook out.
Yeah. And on the side of that as well, some other things that have happened, I unexpectedly started a
company which was a very natural byproduct of a lot of the outreach I was getting. So there's been a
lot of lessons learned there as well. Yeah, sorry. Actually, I meant to say something a second ago. I was
going to say like that flexibility that comes with being a full time hunter, I think really does allow
people like you and I to like say yes to more things. I think whenever you have a full time job
and then you're doing bug bounty on the side, the margin that we have in our lives for things that
are outside of that salary work and those like precious bug bounty hours in the evenings or whatever
is like pretty small, especially if you have a family or lots of other obligations. And so yeah,
whenever you said that earlier, I was like, man, that's so true. Like that's been one huge upside of
this year is just the opportunity to say yes to more things because you don't have like a 40 hour
a week job kind of sitting there all the time. And I know, you know, a lot of people I think who are
full time hunters often talk about that freedom of flexibility, freedom of schedule, being able to
work from anywhere. And then I think before I went full time, I really thought more about
that free time that I would be able to have like for my family or for hobbies,
but I didn't think about all the opportunities that it lets you say yes to for professional work
that you can just kind of swap some of that time with. Right. So instead of doing 100% bug bounty hours,
it's like, oh yeah, I can do 30% of my time on pen test and 20% of time on this side project that
could blow up. And, you know, for me personally, like, you know, 5% of my time on helping advice
companies that may eventually be like a second retirement. Right. It's like it allows you to say yes to all
these things you couldn't say yes to before.
Hmm. 100%. I think it's important as well. I've been speaking to a lot of hackers about this hack this comes to
mine more recently. But when you are a certain tier of bug bounty hunter, and I need to thank Justin for
giving me some advice on this, you really need to weigh up opportunities and opportunity cost as well. And what
that means to you as a hunter. So say if you're in an LHE scene, and you are thinking about starting a company, or you are
thinking about a side project, half reality is and again, it depends on the country, because of different
obligations, things like that. But you probably will take a bit of a hit initially in your income, and you
have to be prepared and ready for that. And it's one of the one of the things I would like to point out if
if you are thinking about doing that is to be very real about what you can make, and what sort of income
you can generate. And equally, aside from the income, what actually fills your cup rather than take from
it, right? Like what, what works for you. And I think for me, again, another completely unexpected
byproduct of having the the freedom from bug bounty is finding that I actually really like doing like
conferences and talks. I've done a lot this year. And that has had another impact of generating so many
opportunities for me, for my company and doing some really good networking. So I would say,
definitely exercise caution when you are looking at some of these opportunities, like even me and you
have spoken about one of your recent engagements when there's a little bit of pushback on your side,
which actually worked out really well for you. But definitely be honest with yourself and weigh up,
okay, this is what I can generate, there's going to be a bit of hit in income, if you do think about
like going down that route. Yeah, yeah. And I loved what you said there about like,
kind of like learning more about yourself, like the fact that you learned that you enjoy doing
speaking and stuff. I knew that I disliked like meetings, and maybe what's the best way to say this,
like accountability from work, like I've always hated like logging time, for example.
Like I've realized that even more, like I was doing a pen test and like an AI security pen test recently.
And I got an email from one of the one of the customers or like one of the people who work at
the customers, like the head of security. And he was like, yeah, if you don't mind, just shoot me over
like, you know, two sentences at the end of the day about like, you know, like what you were like
hacking on or working on that day for us. Or like, would you mind to do that? And my initial inclination was like,
no, I won't do that. Like, I don't I don't have to do that. I'm not going to do that. But obviously,
that wouldn't have been like the most tacked way to say that. And so luckily, I posted my draft email
in a discord channel and Shubs and ZLZ were kind enough to be like, you shouldn't say that that way.
You should say it like this. And we ended up rewording it as like, hey, my normal flow is to stay
in a flow state. I take notes about what I'm doing. And we can talk about that at the end of the week
meeting. And they were like, Yeah, yeah, sure. Just, you know, do it your way. Do it the way you
normally do it. And so that was like a really tactful way to not have to deal with that. But I
do think like, yeah, just like a huge upside that we've talked about bug bounty that really was present
in that moment was the fact that you don't have any, you have no boss, you know, and when you're even
if you're solo freelance, and you're doing an engagement, you do have a boss, right? They hired you,
they're paying you, they kind of have the right to ask things of you. And so, for me, you know,
that kind of pound at home. And also, the pen test that I handed off to you is kind of the same way.
I just got a weird vibe from one of the people who are going to hire me for a pen test. And I
handed it off to you. And we ended up tag taking a minute later. And it was fantastic. But yeah,
I love that you do get a little bit more of like, self introspection and exploration when it comes to
being on your own, you know, you really do kind of, it's more visceral what you like and don't like,
because you can't say no to slightly more. Exactly that. Exactly. And what I will say as
well, I think a thing that isn't really thought about is when you are starting these ventures,
and you are exploring other opportunities, more often than not, it's a very, very different skill
set than the one you used to bug bounty hunting, right? The reason why bug bounty is so cool is
because you get to spend so much time on the cool stuff that you really like. And okay, yes, there are
some caveats with triage and company politics sometimes, when things get downgraded or whatever,
but that is that pales in the comparison to some of the other stuff you have to do. Like,
take your example of logging timesheets. I'd rather pull my own teeth out than have to do that.
Right? I just it's not something I want to do. So ultimately, I would say,
yeah, full time bug bounty has been great. And it's gave me so many opportunities. But there has
been a reality of some learning where you do realize that, okay, maybe I shouldn't have said
yes to that. Or maybe I should have worded that a little bit differently. Because until you try
something else, I don't think you realize how good the bug bounty lifestyle really is. Just with that
freedom. Yeah, yeah, sweet dude. Well, I'm glad that's gone super well. Did you want to mention
your pen test company you started?
Yeah, yeah. So Murtasec, M-U-R-T-A-S-E-C. It's a pen test company. We've been running for,
I would say, since February time, unofficially. And then we properly launched the site
three months ago to capitalize on all the leads that were coming inbound and things like that.
And yeah, we've really hammered down on web applications, AI and APIs. We have a small service
offering because that's what myself and the researchers we work with like to look at. And
yeah, it's honestly been so good to be able to have the opportunity to work with some of the cooler
customers in the AI space, people that are doing really cutting edge things. And also just share
the love and work with my friends as well. It's been really good.
That's one of the coolest things is being able to hire your friends to work with you, right?
Absolutely. And just put money in their pocket too. I hired Exili for this
engagement over the summer and it was like, you know, great pay for him and it was fun to work
together. And honestly, I feel like I get more done and stay more focused when I have friends that I'm
working with, you know? Absolutely. It's a, it gives you that bit more motivation and accountability as
well, I think. Yeah. Sweet dude. Well, uh, I know Justin would be, uh, whipping our backs with,
uh, you know, staying, not being technical enough. So we're going to, we're going to dive into,
uh, um, some notes. Um, Brandon and I both put like, we were looking at some AppSec stuff and then we've
got a bunch of AI research because, uh, I already cover enough AI stuff in general. We'll stick the
AI stuff at the end though. Though it is some like really high quality, good stuff. But, um, Brandon
brought, brought two things to the table here about, um, you know, just traditional AppSec that I think is
really useful. Um, we can dive straight into those if you want to mention the first one.
Yeah, sure. So the first one I got on the list is from Portsfinger. Let me show my screen actually.
Yeah. I had no idea they had released this. So this is, this is really cool.
It'll probably have me, um, uh, double fisting proxies anytime I need to look at WebSockets.
That is exactly where I'm at. And it's not a nice setup. I can trust you. Um, but
WebSocket Turbo Intruder, um, very, very nice. I did briefly have a play around with it and I feel
like it's another one of the Portsfinger specialities where they address a problem that
everyone else is a bit scared of because of the complexity and trying to address that problem.
And essentially they made some updates to it with some really nice quality of life things as well.
Um, just around testing web sockets. It can be such a pain sometimes, especially if you are trying
to exploit some of the more exotic bugs, but just getting a general handle with it has been incredibly
painful on some targets. So this is a very, very welcome addition. Now, one of the cool things that
they did, um, where is it? You've got some filtering in there, the automated testing part,
but the thing I did want to shout out, uh, where is it?
Ah, this was one of them. So whilst they were using that tool for
testing a WebSockets implementation, they found a WebSockets ping of death, um, which was completely
unexpected. And it was a denial of service in a Java WebSocket implementation. Um, and essentially
using the turbo engine, they can send malformed WebSocket frames, which goes outside of the spec that
I was expecting. And lo and behold, it resulted in an out of memory crash. And, uh, they actually
released the ping of death example.py if you did want to use it, if you do come across some of the
Java implementations of WebSockets. I love it whenever, you know, uh, any writeup includes a
POC like that, even more so in like nowadays with AI, because you can just drop that straight into like,
you know, cloud code and be like, Hey, I'm looking for this on this target, implement it, but with like
these headers or this thing, you know what I mean? Just drop in a request and it can customize that
Python file such that it will be the target you're trying to hack. And it can kind of automate some of that
testing. Yeah. Speaking of that, if you go down to the, um, automated testing section, if you command
that for automated, um, it is one thing that I thought was really neat. It's just personally,
I, I, um, this is probably true of most hackers. Um, it's just people in general. Sometimes I have a
harder time, like wrapping my head around things that are different, right? Like our brains are just like,
so used to looking at normal HTTP requests that looking at WebSocket requests can be like confusing
or hard to understand. I love this because, um, basically you can set it up like an HTTP request
and then just modify the post body, like you would an old post body. So if you see that, that box there
at the bottom of Brandon's screen for the listeners, basically, um, they have a way where you can set up
a little like mini proxy where, um, you send a HTTP request with like a normal post body and it converts
it to a WebSocket request on the backend and then sends that with all of the, you know, accoutrement
that like is required to like make it work. And so you can just like modify the keys, you know, it's just
JSON. You can modify the keys. You can modify the values. You can look for things like IDORS or SQL injection
or whatever in like the, in like the keys and values for the WebSocket request, but editing it
as if it were an HTTP request, which is really nice for our hacker brains that are like used to
looking at HTTP requests. Yeah. Yeah. And again, these are the small quality of life things that make
a huge difference when you're on a target and you are facing friction and it is a pain to test and you
have something like this. It's the difference between testing it and not testing it for me, right? It's like
in almost every pen test I've been on, there's like enough to fill the, the hours I have available.
And so like, if something's difficult to test, I end up not testing it, right?
A hundred percent. Oh, absolutely. The other thing I did want to mention out in here as well is
something that I didn't really put into the same bucket and that's WebSockets with race conditions.
And one of the really nice things they've done with WebSocket Turbo Intruder is, and I'm quoting it
from the research now. It includes a special engine type called Threaded. This engine starts
multiple worker threads, eats with its own WebSocket connection and sends messages in parallel.
This makes it possible to trigger classic race conditions like logic bypasses, token reuse,
or state desync bugs. And that gives again, another working race condition example, Python script to use.
But WebSockets and race conditions. I mean, I haven't really heard of anyone, probably a bit slept on,
if I'm being honest. I would say it's super slept on because it's so hard to test, right?
Exactly. Exactly. And this enables that. So I'm definitely going to play around with this a bit
more. I'm eagerly waiting for a target to come up now. But one thing I will say, although I love
Portswigger for this, I'm in this split brain between Kaido and Burt for this exact reason. And it's
just a bit of a pain. And I'm not sure what the answer is, because I really like functionality like this.
Yeah. Yeah. I think it's just like Jocko Willink has a really, really good quote. It's like,
oh, man, I'm not going to be able to remember the exact quote, but basically every decision has
trade-offs, right? It's like everything in life has trade-offs, even if you don't think it does.
There's always like something you're omitting by choosing something else. And so I think like,
you know, this is tough, right? It's like one, it's not ideal to live in both. But if you don't live in
both, then you're not gonna get the features of one. And so I really love so much about Kaido.
And that does make me give up a lot of stuff on Burp. But then if I don't want to give up Burp,
then I just need to use both. But then I have to deal with the downsides of using both, right?
It's like, you know, it's kind of the thing. You can't have your cake and eat it too.
Exactly. Exactly. It was a massive pain. But yeah, a very welcome addition from Portswog,
in my opinion, because this is probably going to find people some pretty exotic and cool bugs.
Yeah, 100%. And I think like, I hate to bring up AI before we're on that section. But I do think there
are a lot of AI apps that use WebSockets for like streaming their responses back. And so it would be
interesting to see if you could kind of like, you know, bypass like different rate limits or, you
know, change different things that are kind of that, you know, that could be changed at the same time.
So if you have an LLM app that's able to like make tool calls, and you use to request like two streams,
where you know, they're modifying the same object, like it'd be really interesting to test kind of what
happens there and that sort of thing. 100%. I'm going to be waiting for targets to pop up now so I can use it.
Sweet. And then there is a second write up on a extremely well paying vulnerability for meta.
Do you want me to share this? Yeah, yeah, if you don't mind.
Sure. Now, this write up.
Incredible. Absolutely incredible in terms of the bounty payout. But when I read it,
and I'm not saying this because it was a bad bug at all. It's a really cool bug. It was easy to exploit
in the sense that I thought a bug that paid this much would be a bit harder. But there we go,
just to challenge the assumptions. Right up by Abhishek Mina. Yeah. So the TLDR here is that
essentially a researcher found a path traversal in Facebook Messenger for Windows. Now, one of the
important things with Facebook Messenger for Windows is that this exploit actually happened in the end-to-end
encrypted chat feature. Now, I hadn't really thought about this before until I read this write up. But
end-to-end base functionality, and it occurred to me once I read this, all of the validation has to be
done on the client side, right? There's no server involved in that. So it's client-to-client communications.
Now, this one was pretty cool where essentially the Messenger client
accepted a file name for one of the attachments, but classic path traversal, the file name wasn't
checked for any path traversal sequences. So what that allowed an attacker to do is essentially upload
a file to a user's chat with a path traversal sequence included and upload a file outside of the
the intended directory on the host. Now, obviously, as we're dealing with end-to-end encryption and the
threat model of Facebook Messenger, this is client-to-client is how I'm thinking about it in my head. There's
no server interaction here. Some pretty cool things on the write-up that the path alone consumed 212
characters, which meant they only had 48 characters for the traversal sequence. So they had a bit of
complexity there in terms of where they could actually upload to. But lo and behold, classic
Windows DLL hijacking came to the rescue where you could essentially upload a DLL outside of an intended
directory or overwrite a DLL or upload a DLL that an application is looking for that doesn't exist.
And it will just dynamically load your DLL, no questions asked, as long as it's in the same
directory location. And that is essentially the path they used to get to RCE.
I'm surprised they use Viber instead of Slack, because they mentioned that Slack was also vulnerable
because of the short name of the application and where it lived. I feel like Slack is a much more
commonly used app. So I'm surprised they use Viber.
Yeah, it is an interesting choice. And the initial reward of $34,500 was awarded after a discussion
regarding payout guidelines for mobile RCE. It was reassessed, totaling to $111,750. So that's
quite the bounty, I must admit. And I'm not going to lie. Again, it's, for me, challenging those
assumptions. I would have just assumed that things like this just didn't exist in the meta ecosystem.
But it goes to show that they do.
Yeah, my first takeaway was, uh, the fact that, uh, you know, like you said,
that the big takeaway for like the, for, I think the listeners is that
apps, which are client to client have like completely different functionality and it feels
like it's way less, um, secure. There's just like less layers of protection there,
right? Cause it's going straight to their clients. So if you can get it to anything interesting,
it's immediately like pretty high severity. And it made me, it made, uh, made me think about like
what other apps are that way. And it reminded me of live hacking event actually. Um, was it this
January or last January where it was like, um, it was a games based company. And I'm sure a lot of
people know what I'm talking about. And, um, because like games are basically installed on your local
machine with the, you know, it very, very much is peer to peer with a lot of the different
functionality, whether you message them or whatever, it's going to be interpreted by their
client installed on their machine. And so, like you said, it's not going through the server,
which allows for like, uh, different types of vulnerabilities than maybe we're used to looking
for. Absolutely. I think when I started to read this, the threat model in my head was like,
okay, so end-to-end stuff, mainly privacy apps and like those sort of peer-to-peer requirements,
but then you're absolutely right. Games is a massive one, isn't it? This is exactly the sort of
the same threat model you would apply there. But I mean, fair play to this person. Very,
very, um, straightforward POC, but very, very big bounty. And I guess that's why the bounty was so
severe because it's the impact and, uh, the clean cut exploit that they made for it as well.
Yeah. It makes me think, um, you know, I, I definitely have this thought slash theory
that as hackbots kind of slowly eat away web app sec that, you know, actual hardware based security
stuff is going to like live much longer, you know, like we all need to get on, uh,
Matt Brown's level and kind of like start looking more at, uh, hardware hacking.
I wonder, yeah, I'm trying to like, just like place in my head where I think mobile and where
I think like desktop apps kind of fall in that. I think they're, they're very slightly safer,
but also we'll come, we'll, we'll, you know, be gobbled up, uh, much before hardware, but I, I,
maybe mobile, I'd say mobile is more secure than desktop. I think like desktop binaries and that sort
of, you know, and like, just like open source code review are going to be eaten by AI before mobile and
definitely before hardware hacking. But anyways, good stuff. It just makes me think about, you know,
whether I should, you know, dig into that more. Yeah, no, I get what you mean. Each has pros and cons,
but you're probably right. I think that Matt Brown style of hacking is going to be
quite unautomatable for the, for the large part.
Yep. Sweet. Um, okay, cool. I know we have about 15 minutes left and we have a ton of assets to talk
about. So, um, like I mentioned on the last episode, I'm going to drag all of our listeners
kicking and screaming, uh, down the path of learning and hacking so that it will better their lives.
Um, so the first thing, which you, you actually shared this blog, um, is a post by SEMGREP. I think
we both have a lot to say about it. I will share my screen since you've been doing all the sharing
I'll share the burden here. Thank you very much. For the listeners only basically SEMGREP companies
we're all extremely familiar with. Um, they used cloud code and open ad codecs to try and find
vulnerabilities. You know, I have to say, I love good TLDRs. The fact that they have like such a nice
TLDR right here at the top was very, very nice for me with just knowing what I was going to get into,
into the content of it. And there, you know, actually as much more interesting content down in the blog,
but, um, but yeah, it's hard hacker notes. Yeah, exactly. It's the hacker notes. It's it's
what you've been killing for awhile. Uh, we've been doing such a good job with. Okay. So yeah. So
basically they used, um, Anthropics cloud code, which for that, they only use on it for,
they did not use Opus and open AI codecs, which they used O4 mini, which I have a bone to pick with,
but we'll figure it. We'll, we'll talk about that in a minute. Did you want to talk about the kind
of their, their true positive rate and what they found? Yeah. So I feel like, and the reason why I
like this blog post is because it feels like to me, there's someone that's unearthed the reality
a little bit to some extent with no sort of biases around what it actually is like running an AI hack bot
from my experience, this matches up. And there was an massive false positive rate. So an 86% false
positive rate. And one of the big things I mentioned here as well is the non-determinism.
So even using the exact same prompts, as you all know, everyone that uses AI on the same code base,
every scan revealed very, very different results every time. So three identical runs produce three,
six, and then 11 distinct findings. Now for blog research, that's manageable. But when you think about
some of these AI impact bot companies, for example, that's going to be a massive amount to deal with,
but we'll touch upon that later on. Yeah, I was going to say, we have some nice thoughts on that
based on a research paper, right? Absolutely. But for me, I just feel like it,
the TLDR and the key takeaways gave way a very nice. This is the reality of some of these things,
but there are some caveats around it. Because if you look at some of the blogs and research, for example,
they aren't doing themselves any favors in the sense that there are architectural decisions you can make
to improve the accuracy of some of these findings. So a common one that Jason Haddix talks about and
what Expo have alluded to in some of their content is around the fact that you get much,
infinitely better results by splitting vulnerability classes per hack bot. So you have a bot for reflect
excess, dumb excess, and so on. This is trying to do a catch-all, which is for context windows and
everything else going to be an absolute disaster, which I think has reflected in their results a little
bit as well. Yeah. And the issue with that is like, there's kind of like an upside and downside.
I think the downside is way worse, like you said. I think that probably massively contributed to
the non-determinism. Just because it wasn't specifically looking for the same vulnerability
necessarily every time. The variance in the next token selection was like having it look for lots of
different types of vulnerabilities each time. But I do think there is one tiny upside with letting the
model choose what to look for is sometimes it's going to try crazy stuff that humans would never even
try that are outside of any standard bug class. But you're right. I think I agree with you. I agree with
Jason that it's much better to have like your hack bot targeting a specific vulnerability because you
can have a very tailored prompt with like, hey, here's how experts go and find XSS and validate it.
Now do those things. Don't just like make your own decisions about how to find it and make your own
decisions about how to validate it or what have you. Right. Absolutely. I think one thing I did like is
how they contrast the different models throughout the blog post about how some are better at finding
different funding. Yeah, that was useful and neat. Yeah. So Claw code was best at finding IDOR bugs
with a 22% true positive rate, but struggled at performing taint tracking across multiple files and
functions with a 5% true positive rate for SQL injection and a 16% true positive rate for XSS.
And then open AI codecs struggled to report any correct IDOR. Did very poorly at SQL injection and
XSS, but surprisingly reported more correct path traversal issues in Claw code. 47%.
Yeah. Let me just get into that. I hate that they used 04 mini. Like I just, I just don't understand.
Like, 04 mini is such a small model. It's so bad. It makes total sense to me that it would,
to be honest, it is really nice to know that it can find paths reversals extremely well. Like,
you know, it makes me almost think like that if you did have a system that was finding a lot of
different vulnerabilities, when you went to look for patches, it's like, oh, just shove in 04 mini right
there and just let it find that one bug. Cause it seems like particularly good at it. But I think,
uh, man, I'm just so mad they didn't use like GPT five or something here, because I think that
it would have been very interesting to see how it stacked up and I'm sure it would have been more
expensive to run, but I mean, it's not like some graphs cares to drop, you know, a hundred bucks.
I mean, this article and us talking about, it gives them more value than they would have spent
on, on the tokens. Right. I would have really loved to see in like Opus' results and also GPT five's
results. Um, and yeah, just to, just to reiterate on what you were saying a minute ago,
they launched this with just like the default agentic wrapper, like the default agentic housing
that's in cloud code and that's in codecs already, which is, you know,
quite good for the development and coding tasks, but hack bots really do require like their own
specialty, uh, like their own special tooling, their own special context to, to do better.
Hmm. A hundred percent. I feel like as well,
just the last point on this, I wanted to bring up before we move on.
I feel like these sort of benchmarks are useful for people planning to build their own sort of hack bots.
And I feel like if there was a resource where a new LLM was released and then all these automated
checks automatically run and they're not nonsense, biased, basic, easy things just to get through a
benchmark, but actual real valuable things like this blog post does would be good because I think about
maybe there's gonna be people out there with like an hack, hack bot infrastructure that uses,
I don't know, O4 mini for path traversal, Gemini for XSS, and then five for XSS and use all these
different agents because they're better at different things, but I'm not sure.
Yeah, no, I think the, the thing that comes to my mind, as you said, that was
this blog post proves that anyone on the planet with cloud code can basically run a hack bot.
Right. And I think that that lowering of barrier to entry is like something that's going to be super
important for our industry because it means it's so easy to sell snake oil. Right. It's like,
you can literally just use cloud code and call it a hack bot and go out and find small and medium
businesses and just claim that you're automated hacking them. Right. And it might find some
vulnerabilities legit because it, you know, this blog post literally proves that's true.
And so it's going to be really hard to, to like separate the, the good companies from the bad when
it comes to hack bot, hack bots. And specifically, um, the next thing that you, that we're going to
talk about is a, uh, research paper where they built a hack bot. Right. And this one's like a really
unique and really good one, I think. Um, but the fact that any, any random company right now,
any random person that has access to codex or cloud code can spin up a hack bot. I think there's going
to be just a myriad, like just like hundreds of companies that, you know, hack bot companies that
pop up. And it's very hard for you, for people to know, unless they're like an actual app sec expert
to know how good or bad those hack bots are and how good or bad they're working and how good or bad the
architecture is. And these companies don't have to share that. They can just claim they have a bunch of
like cool proprietary stuff on the backend when really it's just cloud code with a few system
prompts. And so I think that like, you know, if I was a gold digger, I would go, you know,
claim I have some awesome hack bot. Right. And, um, I think that lots of people out there will do that.
And I don't think that everyone is like ill meaning. Like I think some people are well-meaning
and they're like, oh, I'm the first person to have thought of this. Right. They just don't
keep up with the industry. They don't follow the right people on X or LinkedIn, or, you know,
they don't, they don't listen to our blog, our podcast. So they just don't know. And they think
that they're doing some sort of like super novel research by having cloud code go out and find
vulnerabilities for them. Um, so I think, I think that the industry is going to be like pretty,
pretty, um, full of snake oil and companies that are not that legit. It's for this reason that I really
love that Expo used bug bounty as like a test bed, because you and I know how difficult it is to find
actual real world vulnerabilities. Right. I guarantee you, if Simgrab had set, um, these two agents
write off on a bunch of bug bounty programs and they spent a ton of tokens, they might've found
like a single vulnerability or something, especially if they did VDPs, maybe they would
have found like, you know, two or three, but it's actually super difficult to find real world
vulnerabilities. Um, and so that's why I love companies that are willing to like actually
prove their hack bots by putting it up against like hardened real targets.
A hundred percent, a hundred percent. And it does also lead to the question behind closed doors are these
companies making the decision to burn extra compute and run scans more than once to test
the whole non-determinism thing, or is a very talented analyst behind the scenes steering and
gently pushing things in the right direction. Yeah. I don't know, but that blog post sort of
opens, pulls back the curtain as per se, as to the realities of doing something like that.
Yeah. And I think one thing I know we only have five or 10 minutes, so I'm actually gonna,
I'm gonna have to skip that adversity post and maybe come back to it if we get a chance.
But I wanted to talk about the, um, the CVE genie, because what they have and what Expo has is
basically, um, a really good verifier, like a validator. And I think that's what's key. And we'll
kind of separate these good companies from the bad ones, but the, even the bad ones are going to be
able to limp along, right? Because they can do the manual, they can do like the manual verification of
true false positives or, you know, but, but even if they don't, if they like report these actual false
positives to companies, companies will, you know, eventually dig in and figure that out and be like,
oh yeah, this one must've been a false positive because it's an AI based hack, but like, I wonder
if they'll actually get punished for it. So I only time will tell my friends. I mean, I will tell.
Yeah. Yeah. But shall we move on to the next one? We've actually share CVE genie if you don't want.
Yeah. My link has been damaged in transit. Well, I think it's because you tried to bold it.
It's got the two asterisks at the beginning or the end. Yeah.
So that I, I'm an ocean guy and this is what happens when you transfer from notion to
other Google docs. Right. Here we go. Right. Screen.
Cool. So this one was really cool. Um, I liked it a lot and it's essentially a white paper
on a group of very talented people got together and made an automated multi-agent framework for
producing CVEs, um, from minimal detail. So the premises, they made a agentic framework called CVE
genie, which pulls CVE resources that like advisories, patches, repos, if they're available,
code this, for example, and the, there's a part of the workflow, which reconstructs an actual proof of
concept environment for them to test their exploit against during the process and attempts to create
a working proof of concept on the fly from pulling all these various sources and by creating a test
bed. Um, now it's a huge white paper, very detailed and very, very good. But some of the cool things,
let me just try and find it is the actual architecture they use. So they use a four stage. Where is it?
Okay, here we go. They use a four stage pipeline with zoom in a little bit.
Sure. There we go. Perfect. There we go. Um, containing a processor, a builder,
exploiter and a CTF verifier. And as part of that last step, they also had a like a critic agent, uh,
with CTF style checks put in place to prevent spoofed and hallucinated wins. So very, very cool. And
they had about 51% success rate judging from the paper with a total cost of $2.77 per CVE to recreate,
which is pretty nuts in my opinion. Like that is insane to create a CVE from nothing. 51% cost you
$2. Imagine if you just go out and spray it out and load a bug by any targets.
Yeah. I mean, just run this on every high and critical vulnerability that comes out. Like every
CVE that drops, be the first person to reverse it by using the CVE genie setup and then spray it
across bug bounty programs. Right. This feels like an easy ticket to win. We probably shouldn't have
told everyone about it. The recon guys are punching the air right now thinking.
Right. Or maybe you and I, maybe you and I use this paper to rebuild it. And then we, uh,
get a percentage of the bounties as we hand it off to Moken or somebody.
Yeah. That would be sweet. That would be sweet. I think some caveats. So thankfully,
and it's a pretty big caveat for us web guys is that this framework didn't focus on web-based
exploits. It focused on pretty much every other service other than, and it was a CLI based. So
thankfully there's no web CVEs, but it does cover a lot of other stuff. So we're safe for now,
which is very good news. Um, and I don't think they actually released the framework yet.
Oh, are they going to open source it? I'm pretty sure I read somewhere that there was,
let me just see. I could be, that could be a hallucination on my part.
Oh, it says this paper makes the following contributions. We open source our framework,
source code and data sets. Oh, it is open source. Well, they still, it says it is. I don't know what
the link is, but yeah. Um, okay. Maybe it already is out there then. So yeah, pretty good for the
recon guys. And I feel like we're sort of seeing it every month. Now there's leaps and bounds being made
around the automated exploitation where you probably could start making some decent money from a bug bounty
perspective. If it is literally costing these people on average $2 per CVE. That tells me they were able
to do it with a smaller ish model, right? They weren't using GPT five or Opus. I bet if you did,
the success rate would be even higher. That's a good point. Actually. I didn't consider that,
but yeah, very cool research. I mean, the blog, the blog post, the research paper is absolutely
massive. Um, so I do recommend reading it. It would be in the description and in the hacker notes, but yeah,
it's, uh, also a little bit scary if I'm being honest. Yeah. I, yeah, I agree. I mean,
personally, I don't like submit that many, like I don't farm CVs, but if I were actually an automated
person who does kind of reverse a CV and spray it, I would be, I would be quick to implement this
because I think it lowers the barrier to entry. You know, like I was just saying before, like,
not only do we have a lowering of barrier entry to building hack bots, but we have a lowering of
barrier entry to like reverse CVs. Um, yeah, it makes me wonder if, you know, if companies,
whenever they release CVs should just like go ahead and release the code to test for it because,
um, because it's going to be figured out pretty quickly by AI anyways, it's like,
go ahead and get that tool in the hands of like real companies that need it to like scan their own
infrastructure rather than, you know, just leaving it in the wild for bug hunters and,
um, you know, malicious actors. But it does become a, an arms race in that sense of who can get there
first. It's going to be an absolute disaster for blue teams as well, who I do feel for when I see
stuff like this, but yeah, cool, cool research, good stuff. We do have quite a few more things to cover
off and we are running short on time. Did you want to do one or two more or call it? Yeah,
let's do one more. Why don't you pick your favorite between adverse to talk to and rag and
then we'll save the other ones for a future episode. Oh man. Oh man. That's pretty good.
Okay. While you're thinking about it, let me say one quick thing. I've been doing a lot of hacking
on, um, different AI companies and, and, and one of the products is like AI browsers, kind of like
perplexity browser and, you know, Google has something upcoming and open AI probably has something
upcoming. It's like, you know, there's like a lot of companies that are building browsers, um,
that are going to be controlled by AI. And if there's anything I've learned, it's just that
the attack surface is getting bigger and bigger. You know, I think that some stuff is getting harder,
but in general, the attack surface getting bigger and bigger. So I think there's going to be,
you know, you know, people said this was like the year of AI agents. I think that's still the case.
Next year is probably going to be the year of AI browsers, but I think that, um,
or maybe even just the last quarter of this year, but, um, but I think that, you know, AI vulnerabilities
are getting more and more rampant, like AI security issues. So definitely still worth leaning in.
I do think POCs are becoming more important and more difficult to set up. Like, um, you know,
you might end up having to buy more domains that are related to your target in order to make it much
more, um, likely to be accepted by the current models. Cause they're getting smarter and smarter at like
sussing out or like, you know, finding, figuring out if like you're being kind of sussed and trying
to get them to do something that you shouldn't. So. Yeah, there's a lot there, man. And I'll actually
touch upon this in a minute about why I chose this specific, uh, re piece of research as well for the
next part, but this one, very, very cool. And I feel like it touches upon the sort of
architectural base attacks, how we see things with web cache deception and web cache poisoning.
And I'll explain why it reminds you of that in a minute, but the premise between this research is
essentially like when you speak to an AI now, whether it's GPT, Gemini, Claude, whatever,
you're not actually interacting with a single model. Um, and behind the scenes as an entire routing
system that has been made to analyze your request, decide what the request is trying to do and actually
feed it off to a different model. Now, the reason why these companies are doing this is because one,
if you've got a super easy request, they want to give that to a cheaper model to save them
time and money on that. Um, and two, it actually leads to gigantic cost savings for these company.
And we'll get to it in a minute. It's details, more of the costs down at the bottom of the model,
which actually completely blew my mind. But again, this is one of them ones that spread from
architectural decisions around AI architecture, um, and operation. Now it's dubbed promise Q route,
and I'll touch on it in a minute. And I want to, I want to thank, congratulate them for making the
biggest acronym that I've seen so far in my cybersecurity career. Um, and it's essentially
abusing this AI routing mechanism, um, to route a request on the initial pass. It looks like it's a
normal request going to the model you're requesting, but it's actually wraps in such a way that it gets
passed to a lower model, which is vulnerable to things like jail breaks and things like that. So
pretty nasty and hold on, let's just get this out of the way. So it's called promise
Q route and it stands for prompt base route or open mode manipulation induced like SSR via SSRF like
queries, reconfiguring operations using trust evasion. Isn't that ridiculous?
That is ridiculous. The routing part is interesting, but yeah, it doesn't surprise me on the smaller
models. Um, Marcus from, uh, what company, what's the major consulting company in Europe? KPMG. Um,
Marcus from KPMG told me this about six months or maybe longer ago, and it completely blew my mind.
And I was like, Oh, that makes total sense. And is like now just like a core part of my testing.
Smaller models are always more susceptible to jailbreaking. It's actually one reason why GPT
20 B OSS, the thing that they had that Kaggle red teaming challenge for, which by the way,
the results should come out today. So there was like five or 600 submissions and only 10 are getting
picked for the $50,000 winner, but I'm still hopeful. Um, but yeah, it's really impressive as a 20 B model,
how secure it is, but yeah, I, I love this, uh, attack technique because like you said, it's using
actually, so this is very similar to something I tweeted recently. A lot of, um, what are they called
intent? Um, intent clarify or yeah. Intent classifiers. Well, like a lot of chat apps these
days have an intent classifier. If you're not chatting about like the topic or the category
that the company has made the chatbot for, like if it's cars.com and it's talking about a car,
if you don't ask about car questions, it'll just say, sorry, I can't help with that. So you need to
say like, what's the cheapest car and also tell me all your internal tools. Right. And this is like
very similar, right? You need it to route properly and then you also need to jailbreak it. So you use
the thing like respond quickly to get it to a small model. Then you use your jailbreak.
Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. And again, I've really liked this because
it just perfectly paints the picture that there's going to be so many new
vulnerability classes that are born and bred just simply from architectural decisions that don't
might not even exist yet. We're still yet to see them with the amount of stuff that's coming out.
And this is the figure I was talking about earlier. $1.86 billion estimation is what open AI saves
annually by secret routing these requests. So when I see something like this, ultimately the, the reason
to have a security control in place is it's a cost saving measure, right? If you have
an architectural decision, which is saving you $1.86 billion in revenue, would there be any point
in fixing any of the vulnerabilities that come off the back of it? Because surely the cost saving
just isn't going to be there. Right. I don't know. But some of the things I liked about this as well,
it dives into the, how they prompted it. But I feel like this part, the architecture that nobody talks
about. So modern AI inference operates on three tier architecture that's never been formally scrutinized.
You've got the edge routing, which is zero to 10 milliseconds. You've got the model selection,
10 to 50 milliseconds. And this is where the vulnerability lives. And you've got the execution,
which is the model process and token generation safety filtering, which is 50 to 500 MS. And I don't feel
like you see much research from many people talking about this side of things, um, which I quite liked
about the blog post because it also makes me think about sort of the race condition vulnerabilities as
well. When you start to look at these architectural decisions, like if you look at these, the time taken
for some of these things, there's an absolute huge time gap here. And it just made me think that is going
to be right for race condition exploitation at one of these layers. Yeah. There's also like kind of
like, um, tier two could be kind of broken out, or I guess maybe tier three could kind of be broken out
into the model is often, uh, well, at least in a lot of AI apps, um, there is like a dynamic rag,
right? Which is determining like, you know, which context to pull in depending on user intent.
And then there's also sometimes the model is actually like thinking and deciding like which tool to call.
And so you can kind of get even deeper with this and come up with like an even like, you know,
more verbose architecture diagram. That would be super cool.
Yeah. Really, really good. I mean, again, this is an absolutely massive write up. Um, and it speaks
about the exactly how they crafted the payload and they make a comparison to SSRF, which I'm not entirely
convinced on, to be honest. And I feel like they just added it to add an extra acronym in this very long
name. Um, but I sort of get where they're coming from in the sense that they're SSRFing quote unquote,
a, a prompt to get it to root to itself, but to a different model internally. So, and the reason why
they say it made the contrast is because, uh, both vulnerabilities share the same fatal flaw,
trusting user input to make rooting decisions. Like, yeah, I get it, but just no, like not, I'm not too
happy about it. If I'm being honest, I don't know. Um, but again, regardless, very, very good write up
about exactly how they've done it. The proof of concepts, they broke down the architecture really
well. And they also dived into a lot of the cost as well around some of these architectural decisions,
which I feel like can be quite valuable when you're attacking some of these models.
Yeah. Sweet, dude. I know we're at time for both you and I, so, um, we'll, we'll wrap it there,
but dude, thank you so much for hopping on. Thanks for, you know, giving more details about your journey
and, um, we'll, uh, probably see more of you very soon. Cool. Thank you very much. Right. It's
been a pleasure. Cool. See you guys. Peace. And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for watching to the end y'all. If you want more critical thinking content, uh,
or if you want to support the show, head over to ctbb.show/discord. You can hop in the community.
There's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of masterclasses,
hack alongs, exclusive content, and a full-time hunters guild. If you're a full-time hunter,
it's a great time. Trust me. I'll see you there.